bonjour madame Jean pézieux du magazine
FR3 vendredi je viens pour l'interview
j'ai un petit système que j'appelle mon
gendarme que je n'ouvre pas avant
d'avoir reconnu le visiteur
je méfie il y a tellement de gens qui
peuvent s'introduire chez vous à la
faveur de d'une ouverture de porte les
femmes seules en principe ne se méfient
même pas assez je la passion si la
personne qui pique par exemple
je me méfie même du képi
quand vous sortez de chez vous vous
prenez des précautions particulières
quand je vais dans la rue d'abord je
n'emporte jamais une grosse somme avec
moi et puis enfin si je rentre chez moi
tard le soir
j'aime mieux que la rue soit entièrement
déserte par exemple si je sens à
visiteur derrière moi évidemment je me
mets puis je me retourne vous avez une
cave oui vous y descendez j'y descends
oui mais enfin je j'éclaire d'abord je
méfie un petit peu quand même parce que
dans les caves vous savez il arrive
particulièrement des visiteurs qu'on
peut pas repérer les couloirs de caves
sont assez grands assez obscur
finalement vous sentez pas en sécurité
on ne se sent pas on ne se sent plus en
sécurité nulle part remarqué la police
ne peut pas être partout et spécialement
les femmes seules spécialement les
femmes seules bien entendu c'est bien
plus facile d'attaquer une femme seule
que d'attaquer un homme Victorine et
Louis montarnal vous habitez un petit
pavillon à Rueil-Malmaison dans la
banlieue parisienne
et je crois que vous avez été victime
plusieurs fois d'agressions
introduits chez nous en nous donnant
comme raison sans qu'ils achetaient des
fruits ou autres et ils en profiter pour
inspecter les lieux de la maison et
entre autres celui qui
avait acheté des fruits et qui se
disaient vouloir acheter des meubles il
voulait absolument s'introduire dans la
salle à manger pour voir si j'avais des
meubles s'il y avait des meubles qui qui
l'intéressait alors je l'ai renvoyé je
lui ai dit que je n'avais rien à vendre
et qui ne m'intéressait pas du tout et
de prendre la porte ce que je lui ai dit
mais c'est surtout pour vérifier les
lieux et pour voir dans quel état si
vous êtes capable de vous défendre
est-ce que vous êtes armé monsieur
qu'on a même acheté dans l'occupation
mais j'ose même pas y toucher le
revolver est dans un tiroir avec les
balles mais je me garderai bien
d'emplacer une parce que moi je revolver
il me fait peur on a peur dans la rue
selon vous et comment je ferme la page
ferme ici et puis je guette avant que si
j'entends ce nez je vois un petit peu le
rideau pour me rendre compte vous
laissez plus entre personnes ah j'espère
entre personne si je ne connais pas
on entend tellement de choses qu'on
attaque les personnes âgées on se dit
nous sommes visés
TF1 20h avec Roger Gicquel
bonsoir
la France a peur je crois qu'on peut le
dire aussi nettement la France connaît
la panique depuis qu'hier soir une
vingtaine de minutes après la fin de ce
journal on lui a appris cette horreur un
enfant est mort un 12 enfants au regard
profond assassiné étranglé où étouffé on
ne sait pas encore l'autopsie ne l'a pas
complètement révélé par le monstre qu'il
avait enlevé pour de l'argent et oui ce
qui nous est frais c'est que ce type
ressemble tellement à n'importe qui et
c'est pour ça que la France a peur alors
pour moi cette réflexion elle elle était
je crois proche de la sensibilité du
public alors d'où vient le trouble le
trouble c'est que je me suis rendu
compte qu'ensuite ça avait participé
probablement un entraînement de
l'opinion vers ce ce qui était déjà en
gestation ce qui était préparé
c'est-à-dire une un esprit de de
vengeance terrible et de et de de
justice expéditive
esprit alimenté toute la journée sur les
radios et plus tard dans ce même journal
par les déclarations de ministres que
vous connaissez
est-ce qu'on peut pas s'interroger sur
le rôle des médias dans ce développement
de la psychose collective de peur et de
vengeance
je crois que le crime le crime existe
dans dans la société quand temporelle
maître Badinter dit qu'il faut
s'habituer à vivre avec le crime parce
que ça existe
il faut s'habituer à en avoir le moins
peur possible mais je crois que
éliminer le crime de l'information
c'est vraiment jouer la politique de
l'autruche il est préférable de traiter
le crime comme une information mais
d'essayer de désamorcer toute cette
panique qu'il y a autour du crime
c'est c'est très difficile à réaliser
parce que
je vis dans un corps professionnel qui a
des réactions et qui sont des réactions
de journalistes qui ne se posent pas de
question il ne faut pas que le
journaliste se pose toujours des
questions c'est presque je dirais qu'il
y a des moments c'est le contraire de
son métier de se poser de question de
savoir s'il doit couvrir telle ou tel
information président lui-même de la
République l'a écrit notre société
actuelle
à rarement connu autant de sécurité dans
la vie de tous les jours que dans les
siècles passés c'est vrai que sortir à
Paris la nuit à certaines époques des
siècles derniers étaient quelque chose
autrement dangereux que même maintenant
c'est vrai aussi que habitué à des
périodes de très grandes sécurité dès
que vous avez un incident nouveau qui
est colporté par la rumeur alors la peur
naît même si l'incident a été minime
ou même même si c'est un incident
relativement important mais qui quand
même proportionnellement ce qui peut se
passer dans le pays et peu de choses
le petit village de Somme Dieu dans la
Meuse en mars 1975 à la sortie du bal
une véritable bataille rangée oppose les
habitants à une bande de jeunes la
première milice était née aux armes
citoyens mais si par exemple de tels
événements se reproduisaient est-ce que
de nouveau vous sortiriez les fusils
vous avez l'impression que les gens ne
comprennent que la force que les armes
en l'occurrence avec la police
et ça a diminué la peur selon vous des
gens
c'est-à-dire quand les gens viennent
quand même à son milieu et tout mais on
va même attention
faut pas rigoler mais on nous dit par
exemple à Évry qui se passe pas
grand-chose on a en interview les gens
ils nous disent pas sans rien à tout le
monde veut garder sa propre sécurité
depuis Noël mais il n'empêche que la
nuit de Noël et les jours d'avant les
caves de toute la région ont été payé
tout le monde le sait que ça soit au
bonhomme en pierre que ça soit
rue Jean Mermoz dans tout le quartier ou
que ça soit là-haut du côté de la rue
Mathilde et partout il y a des caves qui
ont été payés au moment de Noël les gens
ont été surpris de ne plus retrouver ni
les bouteilles mais ce qu'ils avaient
préparé pour les fêtes c'est connu ça et
personne ne dit rien
ils ont bien réussi à voler tous les
joueurs de Noël et aucun parent a
répondu aucun parent n'a manifesté sont
mécontentement et en général là ceux qui
font du vandalisme dans ce quartier dans
le territoire il y a des jeunes bien sûr
comme partout ça c'est sûr vous les
connaissez on arrive à en connaître
quelques-uns il y en a quelques-uns du
reste ici qui ont été pris qui ont été
arrêtés
et je crois que maintenant vous prenez
des précautions vous n'avez pas
l'intention de vous laisser faire
une chose c'est qu'on a monté la garde
et il nous arrive encore de monter la
garde les uns les uns et les autres on a
le téléphone les uns et les autres et je
vous garantis qu'il faut pas qu'il nous
tombe dans les mains on a des tricks on
a ce qu'il faut et on les reçoit on les
recevra dignement croyez-moi est-ce
qu'il serait pas plus juste de dire
qu'il y aurait aussi une peur que les
gens ont qui est plus forte peut-être
que l'insécurité
ou une voiture volée n'importe quoi bah
il y en a ils ont l'impression que
l'heure elle a été visité aussi là lol
ils reviennent le lendemain ils vont
porter plainte comme quoi on a volé des
trucs dans leur voiture il y a rien de
voler regarde pas il referme la porte il
va faire ma clé donc commissariat ils
disent voilà on va fouiller dans ma
voiture
et dans les parkings dans les cas il se
passe jamais rien en balance
[Musique]
des histoires que c'est obligatoirement
nous dis pas que c'est vous mais il se
passe bien quelque chose ici non
[Musique]
comme ça qui est-ce qui dit du mal de
vous alors les gens du quartier tout ça
[Musique]
les jeunes simplement et quand vous
amusez vous amusez à quoi
bon le voyou est un bien grand mot et
puis ça permet aux gens de mettre des
tas de choses sur ce mot voyou moi je
les appelle des oiseaux parce que ce
sera très drôle comme on dirait des
nounours ou n'importe quoi sont des
gosses qui ont envie de jouer qui ont
envie de s'amuser qui sont livrés à
eux-mêmes du matin jusqu'au soir et
imaginez-vous de leur âge tout seul du
matin jusqu'au soir dans les rues on en
invente c'est des gosses qu'on ne
l'imagination mais de l'imagination qui
est souvent un petit peu dangereuse et
un peu embêtante
et puis il y a ce que les autres
il y a le fait que quand vous êtes tout
seul si un garçon rentre ici et qu'il a
une agressivité qu'il est qu'il est de
mauvaise humeur parce que il a manqué
l'école parce que chez lui on sait pas
qu'il a pas été à l'école parce qu'il
s'est disputé avec sa mère etc
il rentre ici la maison reçoit son
agressivité il est tout seul on peut
dialoguer
on en parle ça se détend ils sont deux
c'est la violence parce qu'il faut
montrer aux copains qu'on sait pas avoir
qu'on se laisse pas piéger qu'on se
laisse pas posséder bon là dans la rue
c'est la même chose on est tout seul on
touche la voiture
ça va pas bien loin on est deux on est
calé on montre aux copain que on est un
petit peu plus fort quoi donc on en
rajoute bien sûr
[Musique]
quand on parle d'insécurité de peur
on pense tout de suite et les gens bien
pensant on pense tout de suite aux
jeunes aux migrants aux ouvriers
migrants
et à tous ceux qui sont dans une
situation de minorité ce sont eux qu'on
voit dans les journaux dans les masses
médias dont on parle à propos d'actes de
violence mais en réalité si on réfléchit
qui est responsable des actes de
violence des jeunes ou des migrants ce
n'est pas le jeûne qui fait comme un
acte de violence à Paris ce sont ceux
qui ont organisé la société d'une
certaine manière même à Paris dans
l'urbanisme parisien combien de mesures
auraient pu être prises actuellement en
faveur des jeunes
lorsque on a pratiqué des opérations
dites de rénovation dans Paris et quand
on a exclu
toute une série de familles ouvrières
qu'on a déporté pratiquement dans des
zones de banlieue on les a envoyés dans
des grands ensembles ou on avait
construit des cités qui n'étaient
absolument pas préparés pour la vie
ouvrière les jeunes qui sont élevés dans
ces conditions qui sont désemparés qui
n'ont pas d'activité culturelles
suffisantes qui n'ont pas les moyens de
se réunir entre eux ils vont exploser à
certains moments et on va les accuser
mais qui est responsable qui est
responsable est-ce que ça n'est pas ceux
qui ont construit ces grands ensembles
sans vouloir réfléchir alors que on
aurait très bien pu éviter certaines
erreurs est-ce que ce ne sont pas ceux
qui ont voulu exclure les familles
ouvrières de Paris trop rapidement
est-ce que ce ne sont pas ceux qui n'ont
pas prévu des espaces verts qu'on avait
demandé
finalement vous voulez apparaître comme
des gens comme tout le monde
on se dit pas des gens mieux on se dit
pas des gens moins bien on est on est au
même niveau que
c'est pas vous qui leur fait peur aux
autres ceux qui sont pas
[Musique]